on here keep bringing it
[Music]
Forward canot tilt
him get his Center come forward
okay and then it comes to this hand and
then the two hands the two hands are
doing it so don't tilt again the two
hands have to be in his Center and
bringing him forward
two hands BR
this up this hand
here so when you take him all the way
down this hand he's down this hand is
the kazushi he comes up
here body
this
s this
okay
try if he does not go all the way down
you still have to control his Center
okay but then the kazushi hand is is the
other
[Music]
hand he's still need his Center to go
forward this hand's going to help a lot
more this way
what I mean by that is this this hand
does
this this sound's not in place to do the
same thing and the other
one I'm over here I can do this
whole
big this one it's only little you see
little this hand does
full body
[Music]
in
here here I get one
hand
here don't just go
here turn it turn turn
it this
time okay
try Okay in both
techniques in both techniques his Center
has to move forward okay once it moves
forward here's where I break balance and
I stay in the back he comes around I'm
in the back always in the back it comes
around I'm in the back in the back I'm
in the back stay there I'm in the back
of
him and this one does the
kazushi again I have to move his whole
body
in and I stay in the back
in the
back in the other one same thing I have
to move his whole body and I'm in the
back I'm in the
back and it starts from
here so I'm in the
back and this hand does it
don't go here you're in the
front move him there I'm in the back in
this hand do
it okay
try so you know that you want him to be
in this
position see that's the back outward or
the back inward position okay this
isn't and this
isn't so if you if you bring him all the
way down because you Tenon see if
because I ten con i t
con he's not where my arm can be in
other words if I bring him into this
arm I'm going to be in front of him and
he's not in the right position he's
supposed to
be
here so when I ten
con and I smash his head
down this is also not the right position
so when he goes up that's when I bring
him forward and there it is right there
this is the right position
he's not in the right
position 10
con
forward there it is right
there and the other one if I bring him
down here he's not in the right
position he's
here so if I bring him
back here I'm just pulling him and I'm
not in position for the
throw I have to bring him
forward there it is right
there
see don't mix the
two don't t con and bring him here
you're this is muscle
resist I'm not going to get it but if I
bring It Center forward then I get it if
you t con you take them all the way down
okay on the other one it's more
sideways so he's coming in
right when he passes name I go
here okay not in
front this isn't it I have to take his
Center
and turn
it okay so whatever the the technique
you
use it's not that his Center stays in
space there at the edge of at the tip of
the Joe that's not what happens and then
I pull his head back that's not it his
Center is going to actually go forward
in space this way you see and then and
that's the
position so that's the second technique
on the first technique it's the exact
same
thing okay so here he
is and his Center's
there it's not that I pull the head
back I have to move his Center
forward the center goes forward okay all
right try